andy did you watch the golden globes i i
did yeah
it's been really interesting to see how
big award shows are produced
during this pandemic uh because of all
the restrictions
and oh wait what's what's going on andy
what's happening
uh well i think al pacino accidentally
zoomed into our show
what's he doing um it looks like he's
being observed on one of those bald
eagle live cams
mr pacino can you hear me
mr pacino the golden globes are over
wow that was weird yeah well the the
whole show was weird i mean with people
zooming in from different places it's
just it's a different time right now i
mean i thought
uh all the celebrities did the best they
could um
and and tina fey and amy poehler were
really funny it's just we just have to
get used to this new way of watching
uh these award shows
[Music]
mr pacino mr pacino you did it again
why is he clapping mr pacino you need to
hit the leave button
hit the leave button it's a red button
on your screen
can he even hear us though you need to
hit
the leave button what what's going on
here i just think he turned off the
camera
uh i don't know okay mr pacino you're
still here
the camera's off but you're still here
what why what is the show over yet
no no you what the [ __ ] no we're still
here you need to hit
i'm in the dark here you're still here
why am i still hearing that tilda
swinton broad yammering away god's sake
now that's a national treasure
you don't think i'm in pacino category
yet
you know that's okay